across all the other practices in
trafford
as soon as there is the space to be able
to actually do that
so from my perspective they're the
highlights from the
data in the report and i'd be quite
happy to answer any questions about it
so the in the expert program and the
diagnosed yes that's type two
yes we're focusing on the type two for
this this is the preventable type one is
is not
related to lifestyle or
um there is some element of it being
related to you know ethnicity and other
risk factors
but no this is about type 2 diabetes
even though i'm right next to you i will
use this because alex has told me we're
streaming so um
uh yeah i just got a couple of questions
really about the rollout when you're you
know allowed to do that when you know
restrictions will permit um and just um
how will how would you target um kind of
inequalities across trafford so when you
roll it out is it a kind of sheep dip
everybody through that or is it more
targeted in terms of you know certain
sets of surgeries one after the other
and then and i guess
what's the kind of risk for this
as ccg goes to ics
as well because could it fall in a in a
crack there is no question really
there's some big questions aren't they
so the the prevalence data that is
within the report that clearly shows
that we've got a greater instance of
diabetes in the population in the north
of the borough
and secondly the west of the borough
um
demonstrates that we should prioritize
our limited resources on those areas
so you know it's going to be a gradual
rollout and it will be prioritized
but i can't be any more specific than
that because we just don't know when the
infection prevention control measures
are going to be changed in healthcare
settings but you know that's why your
gps are continuing to behave the way
they do and you know the digital access
that we've got across a lot of our
practices is gonna have to evolve
into a new way of working as those
restrictions are reduced
um
we are already
preparing a handover document for
our change over into the ics and
many of the existing ccg staff
will be uh two peop transfer over into
the ics and many of them will probably
be within the locality
again the the icb which is the nhs
employing organization within the ics
hasn't really got
a management structure
never mind the rest of the organization
at this point in time so it's impossible
to be
specific about which members of our
existing team
will be
working within the locality still in
trafford or maybe working elsewhere um
but you know whether they are or not
we're already creating the document
about all the worker undertaking all the
issues and everything that won't need to
be carried on when the ccg ceases to
exist
personally i i imagine it's going to
take a year or two for the icb to get
organized so things are likely to
continue as they have been
at least for the first few months
um i just wondered what you're doing um
to
get across the importance of the health
checks and you know to attract people um
who speak
who don't
speak english as a first language or or
have you know
less
good understanding of english
so
the the targeted program that's happened
in partington
has not
particularly had those communication
difficulties so i don't think the
resources
that partington have used in have been
available in um
in a a wide range
but
you know for for north trafford we
already produce lots of the health
information in in multiple formats to be
able to address that and i would imagine
as it's extended that would be continued
although i
haven't got into that level of detail at
this point in time
but but we we you know
big thing learning through the pandemic
it is it has highlighted our
inequalities and we shouldn't be doing
anything without considering that and
addressing that appropriately
yeah and i guess i would just say that
like partington does have a very
different ethnicity makeup to the north
of the borough and so
there would be different approaches
needed to improve
um the role out there and obviously
partington you know are doing really
well but
there will be different things that need
to be considered absolutely yeah that
that was the try point i was trying to
make what has worked in partington will
have to be
localized as we move to other areas it's
worked well there
it's identified the higher risk groups
and it's been effective for them but
the same plan will not be an identical
lift and shift
just to say that um in terms of the um
health check model
we are thinking about alternative models
and within that thinking um
to um respond in particular to your
concerns around um
language and the needs of different
communities is
we would consider alternative providers
and potentially voluntary sector um
or
for example leisure providers so
potentially diversifying
the health check offer
so that it can be tailored to the needs
of different communities and we're
exploring um those options at the moment
just a couple of points you mentioned
that
trafford is above greater manchester and
and the national average
has that been has it been identified
what trafford is doing
better then particularly at the the
greater manchester authorities and is
his work being done to get that message
out
um no
the honest answer i i think part of it
will be a large number that have been
done in partington because we're we're
looking at very small proportions of the
population even the additional number
done in partington will have an impact
on the whole of trafford figures
um because they're very small
proportions of the population we're only
talking about i think it was at 1.8
nationally sorry my laptop shut itself
down so i can't see it so it's only one
point eight national percent nationally
and we're only two or three percent so
even those kind of numbers
that part that trial in partington will
have
had a significant impact on it
but i haven't looked any more detail
than that
[Music]
and the
training program that you mentioned to
prevent becoming
diabetic
um
are they people who are um operating
that finding that this
good take-up or is there a bit of a fear
factor around getting involved in it
i i haven't got any of the data i don't
know whether dealer knows i i don't know
um i know for partington it's been
effective but i don't have any of that
detail to hand i'm afraid
i believe we achieve a conversion rate
of about 50 percent so that's 50 percent
of people referred to
show up at least to their first
assessment and appointment but that's
not complete in the program
and
i don't think we're different uh from
other areas in that i think that has
been an issue nationally um yeah
i take your point that it's an issue
nationally it sounds like
something that somebody needs to do a
bit of work on doesn't it to
get a bit more buy-in
but
uh obviously 50 is uh
better than nothing so
a good result there
um
i haven't got any other questions myself
is sorry
just
for clarification how long is this
course last because it's not
a week or it's actually
it's quite a commitment for people to do
it i think
isn't it
i'm not absolutely certain but off the
top of my head i think it's six weeks
so yes it is
and and
it is a
big lifestyle change for most people um
and it'd be easier not to do it in a lot
of ways for a lot of people as well
so uh so you know
part of it is is how well the gp
or the person doing health check if it's
not going to be gp motivates
the patient at that point
um
because you know
their risk of a lot of other health
problems is high unless they make
significant lifestyle changes
and if they have that motivation for the
outset i think they're more likely to
follow it through um
if if it's not really mentioned why
they're doing it at the outset i think
the uptake is going to be lower
um
so so it's it's about having that
consistent message across the whole of
the system which which is now improving
[Music]
yeah i think just to follow up on the
last couple of questions
really around the
well the take-up of both the health
checks and the and the diabetes program
actually so
how how
would you
recommend that we as a committed judge
the success of those programs because
i you know i can see this data and about
inequalities between you know north
south different parts of the bureau so
i can see that we obviously want to
reduce those
inequalities but
in in a way they're a statement of of
what the data shows we don't necessarily
know that those inequalities have
narrowed because of health checks or
diabetes checks so i guess what i'm
asking is
for those people that and it's in its
small numbers you know compared to the
12 000 on the diabetes register and
there's
797 going into the
diabetes program and then yeah 51
um
go beyond the first session so you know
three and four about 400 people so i get
how do we know
whether the diabetes program has been
effective for those people do they
you know do we would we see the number
of people with diabetes drop would we
see them
are they are they tracked after the
program to see whether they
are no longer obese and and i suppose
this is the same question for health
checks really so
the data in the report is all about
how many people what proportion of
people
take up the health checks
um
which is good but how effective are
those health checks in
spotting a condition that somebody
wasn't aware of or ensuring people get
treatment for a pre-existing condition
that's what i don't think um
through the report that's a great
longitudinal study that um
that you're proposing um
the
the chain the
outcomes the complications of diabetes
often only show 10 to 15 years later so
if we're going to judge the success of
the
expert program helping diabetics to live
healthier lives
it's going to take a long time for us to
have significant outcome measures if you
use proxy measures like weight that you
mentioned then you may be able to get
give some indication
and
improvements in hba1c the
tests that we use to monitor diabetes do
show strong correlation to the risk of
complications so short term we could use
that as a measure
um and that's also the hbo on c is
probably the best measure for
um
for the pre-diabetes for the early diet
for the prevention and the success um
although we haven't set in motion any
follow-up programs to actually assess
that
at this point in time
um
[Music]
the younger members of their family
be allowed to go with them so they can
they can learn themselves so this is not
replicated in the next generation
so the
the risk for the south asian communities
higher but i don't think it's all
environmental i think some of it is
genetic from the research i don't think
it's exclusively um
behavioral
um
i'm not sure of the detail of how that
program works i i can't imagine why you
will now allow support but i'm not
actually familiar with that level of
detail of the programme
is very largely genetic rather than
like due to behavioral differences
i'll go to item five now the uh
item on domestic abuse
and
i'm not sure
so i haven't got a note of your name if
you could introduce yourself for me
please um
and this is following a previous report
to the healthy uh committee
in january 2021.
so it's set to see prior to july
2021 we had no commissions perpetrator
proficient uh within trafford and we
were taking the approach of spot
purchasing uh poetry division pursues
user via inner strength and authorism
change
this had its barriers and its risks with
the fact that it was three and a half
thousand pounds per service user if they
were known for social care called in the
criminal justice system we also have no
robust way of monitoring the
effectiveness of this provision
in 2020 2021 we agreed to work together
forty seven thousand eight hundred and
seventy five pounds for perpetrator work
by us of 30
we can therefore um say there is a
significant gap
within trafford for perpetrators of
domestic abuse and this has been
highlighted since then in the domestic
abuse act the received royal ascent in
april last year is now entrained in law
one of the four aims of that act are to
transform the justice process by
providing an effective response
thank you very much before
well not for questions i just want to
say
um i'm new to this committee
and i have to say that
i just don't really understand
domestic violence
and the more i
um look at it um the more complicated it
gets to me i just i
i just find it
um
i don't know
something that i just cannot get my head
around
really and it makes it very i just feel
it must be a hugely difficult
topic
for people like yourselves
to work in the
it must be full of
i don't know cryptic clues and traps and
all sorts of things that uh and
you know having to see in the dark or
whatever
i'm probably sounding a bit crazy here
but i'm just
trying to
um
sort of scene set a little bit for
myself
from my point of view how um how i
perceive it as such a very difficult
area and for those people working it
i've got nothing but admiration so thank
you very much for all for all that you
do in that so having gone on a bit too
long i'll just
open up for questions
uh council car do you want to go first
[Music]
thank you for that i've got um a few
questions
um so you mentioned before that you
didn't know
obviously there was a there's a
considerable cost saving with this and
and it sounds like
um
you know a very um
a really good offer particularly
compared to what was in place before but
how do we know if this is effective
because you said we didn't know whether
the previous offer was effective how do
we know whether this is effective
so um make a change has been um
monitored for a number of years it is
accredited by respect in consultation
with women's aid and there's a there's a
huge evidence base
a change to ensure that it is effective
now that is on a national scale um and
if we're looking specifically at
trafford we need to monitor the
effectiveness for trafford to ensure
that it fits in with what our specific
needs are and that will be done via the
quarterly reports and monitoring outcome
meetings um we are very confident in our
partnership with talkless and change um
we are very confident with talkless and
change as the service provider um and as
greater monsters perpetrator and service
with with a wealth of expertise and
experience in that
um so again we've already met with them
twice uh since the launch of this and
had those monitoring outcome meetings
um gathered that feedback we know they
already have launched one of the groups
and that's already gathering um some
outcomes for those for those service
users that are accessing that so um
all i can provide so far maker change
and cuip is what's historically been
done
but since this provision is new um it
only launched its first group in
december um we haven't got that evidence
based just yet but that is exactly what
this pilot approach will do
i'm sorry i've got a few questions but
it's so it's an area that's very
important uh to me um
so my next question is obviously this is
quite a new program
um is there any risk
that demand will start to outstrip
supply so what is your
so sorry that
yeah that the demand for this service
will start outstripping you know the
capacity for
um you know for support is that a
possibility
i mean it's a really good point uh um
you know what we know from the joint
strategic needs assessment uh um is that
we we had 84 perpetrators known to
probation um but also we need to be
aware that probation have their only
internal um perpetrator program so
building better relationships for high
risk and help for our low and medium
risk so we shouldn't be service reliant
on tlc for all the work that needs to be
done around perpetrator work the funding
we have um allows us to meet these
numbers um so far we haven't seen any
influx referrals
we're actually at that point of
repromoting these provisions to get
those referrals up within trafford so i
don't see a risk at the moment at all
with us not being able to meet that
demand but again this is something that
we need to monitor um and i think if we
did see an influx i can see that as a
positive because it means the the
program is effective uh it's meeting
demand um and again it's preventing
domestic abuse which is our overall aim
within trafford
so again it's just about monitoring if
we do see that increased demand
and lack of resource then it's about
reviewing that
okay thank you i've got a few more
questions um
so uh this is delivered in partnership
with women's aid and obviously we are
aware that um
women are
more often the the victims and survivors
of domestic violence and and serious um
physical um abuse and fatality related
to domestic violence however there are
obviously a large group of male victims
um and uh i guess an increasing group or
or a particularly at risk group would be
those um in same-sex relationships
particularly when it comes to male
victims um
is is this open to to any
to those in same-sex partnerships and um
and you know to to male victims as well
and what are we doing to kind of
capture um those perpetrators and and
you know to support those victims and
and um
survivors in this program absolutely and
thank you for that question
um i think it's really important that we
consider intersectionality we consider
those protected characteristics um and
we are inclusive in our approach and
that is something that is high on my
agenda um and yes absolutely
males in same-sex relationships can
access this um this perpetrate provision
however we know with lgbt plus
relationships the dynamics experiences
the barriers do differ um so again
that's where those open lines of
communication with talkless and change
come in
talkless and change also have a uh women
who use violence program so not
something we commission in trafford but
is available if we do have presentations
now with regards to the victim side um
which tdas provide that support um we
have just commissioned for a male
domestic abuse advisor that again is
providing that group support and
one-to-one support to male victims
within trafford and that is inclusive of
uh lgbt plus uh victims and those from
other protect characteristics
so yeah i am confident that uh we can
pick up those needs and the referral
pathways to lgbt services such as lgbt
foundation are embedded so that
specialist by and far services are
included within the service delivery and
within those referral pathways
great thank you sorry last question um
obviously this is quite a new um
service and you know one that
has a lot of promise um and you know has
a really good offer
and one that is you know very cost
effective much more so than the previous
offer what are we doing um
to
improve awareness of it and you know
referrals into the service
yeah so there is a workforce development
aspect to make a change in this funding
within that so um
they have delivered training to trafford
staff i think it's up to 69
professionals so far um and these
training sessions um are ongoing for any
multi-agency partner within trafford
not just to raise awareness of uh
perpetrators of domestic abuse but also
to provide that service uh promotion for
maker change um so we have talkless and
change attend many boards they've
attended many practitioners boards um
roundtable events um and they are
promoting the service widely so that's
one of the main ways we are promoting
that service
um but of course there are the other
means as well so we've got the digital
posters we've got the social media
promotions
and they are available to anyone um
whoever wants them
thank you very much
okay can i just say uh counselor can't
you never apologize for asking questions
that's what we were here for and those
were very uh important questions that
you were asking there so it's uh it was
good to hear
that level of uh
detail being explored so thank you for
that um councillor hartley
[Music]
thank you chair and
well like you i i
i think i struggle with domestic abuse
because of the
the variety of ways in which it you know
manifests itself so um
and and i thought this report was really
interesting in highlighting some of that
you know particularly
um abusive relationships among children
young people um you know abusive parents
and carers as well as the
i guess you know the traditional sort of
impression of domestic abuse is you know
the the the male perpetrator and a
female victim and obviously that's a
a large part of um of domestic abuse
i think so on
on that sort of theme do you know um
so i i know one of the one of the things
that has become
uh there's been much more attention
about has been
different forms of domestic abuse not
just violence and you know political um
particularly psychological uh abuse
coercive control in relationships and i
think um
from from what little i've heard i think
i think the police have struggled with
this in terms of investigating and
charging people because i think it's a
it's it's a it's a longer course of
events it's not a one-off event of
violence so i just wanted
on the perpetrator program is it is it
predominantly
um perpetrators of physical abuse or
other perpetrators of psychological or
other forms of abuse as well
yes so i think it's important to note
that make a change is not for our high
risk perpetrators
that's not to say that physical abuse
won't be present um because it
definitely could be um and make a change
is not a one-size-fits-all approach
either so it really will deal with all
forms of abuse
and i think you know again that's a
really important comment to raise there
are different forms of abuse and i think
it's layered i think it's where
practitioners ability to identify those
different forms of abuse and record that
and provide the support which is
tailored to those different forms of
support but we've got the other side and
our joint strategic needs assessment
fund that where victims and perpetrators
alike are not acknowledging those
non-physical forms of abuse as domestic
abuse um and from our jsna that was the
most commonly form of abuse so it it's
part of a wider picture um the
non-physical forms of abuse along with
economic control and coercive behavior
it's our role to ensure that victims are
aware that that is domestic abuse um and
that we're recording that appropriately
but um yes in short and uh to your
question this will cover all forms of
abuse uh including physical abuser
knowing that the the high risk mapper
cases will be with nps not with make a
change
thank you that's um yeah really
interesting to hear really really
welcome to here um i had one other
question uh chair of if that's okay
which was um
um you mentioned this in your in your
report around um
the funding so the department for
leveling up hosing in communities
funding for domestic abuse is ring
fenced um for the second consecutive
year for accommodation based services
only
um
now i can
i can sort of
suggest what up why that might be but i
don't know if i'm right i suppose my
thinking is because of the pandemic
there was a there was a lot of
attention and a lot of worry and we had
worry in this committee i can remember
about
um lockdown and people being stuck in an
abusive relationship in an abusive home
um but i think i think you said
something around um
there's there's more demand for the
community based services or there was
something around you um perhaps you
could maybe clarify that and just um
do you is that the reason why the
department are ring fencing the money
and
um
is that like a change do you think
just wondered why they've got that sort
of policy of only funding
accommodation-based services yeah
absolutely so accommodation-based
services for victims of domestic abuse
was highlighted as a specific need um
but specifically why um
formerly mhclg um have ring fenced it is
because with the domestic abuse act
there is a duty on all tier one local
authorities to provide
accommodation-based services to any
victim and their children um so this
funding is to support us with meeting
that duty under that um new act and that
new legislation um but that's not
dismissing the point around covid19 and
and other societal changes that have led
to an increase in demand and
specifically an increasing complexity
for victims and families um during the
pandemic and what we have seen in
trafford and i would argue nationally is
that increase in demand and housing is
definitely one of those things um but
that again that consistent lack of stock
um is still present um this isn't a
traffic specific issue this is national
um so it so yes specifically around the
funding ring fence because of that duty
um from the act um
however there is obviously still a huge
demand for community-based services and
that's what makes it really difficult um
from a commissioning point of view that
we've got these vital community-based
services like perpetrator programs
and we obviously commission loads of
other community-based services for
domestic abuse but that lack of that
lack of dedicated funding
i am hopeful that now the victims bill
is going through that process
we will fingers crossed have um
dedicated funding for community-based
services um that would be the ideal
situation but if i if we're only
speaking about currently um it is based
on external funding um and also our
multi-agency commitment um from partners
uh we can't deal with domestic abuse and
isolation um it is a commitment from
every agency um it can't just sit within
me in community safety we do need that
investment from everyone
so again with regards to make a change
and other perpetrated provision
it is about shared responsibility and
ownership for that
and
i'm thinking
our
fans
the for make a change it's a 26-week
program and victims um can be supported
throughout the duration of all that so
it is a 26-week program with with that
service user
um and for children and young people
that's 10 to 16 weeks and for the
respect young people program and six
weeks for the healthy relationships and
again for anyone else affected within
that family um
by that domestic abuse there is that
victim support that integrated victim
support that can be for the duration of
that time as well
fact that that individual is
part of that relationship and it's that
that is controlling it yeah and um i'm
just thinking you know there's been
thousands of
young people
and it's not necessarily going
yeah the prosecution rates for control
and coercive behavior are low and i
think it's because um you know as
previously was said it's really
difficult to gather that evidence um and
put that case across um
that's not to say that it shouldn't be
um but again it comes down to
ability to
record that appropriately so that it is
in that crime category which sometimes
does get missed
for the um
ones who were only able to join us a
little bit late we've um
taken the agenda slightly out of
sequence so we've already dealt with
item six we've just done
item five
so we're now going to
item
seven
and the adult social care update
and
it's yourself dan
um it is thank you chair johann harding
sends her apologies she's actually on
holiday um
today
um
and i'm really pleased really to be
coming back to present a better picture
this this month and last month you
remember last month i updated you on the
framework for decision making that we'd
put in place
as we hit the omicron um variant wave
and the issues that we'd had with
availability of staff particularly in
our home care resources
and i talked you through some of those
steps that were taken but also the
pressure it was placing across the
system both in community with around
4000 people that we support all the time
and across our acute set to provision
with hospital discharges however we are
in a considerably better place
so we have stabilized the situation
we've brought a lot of additional
capacity into the market into the care
market and we've got some further work
to do on stabilizing that into more
long-term contractual frameworks and um
considering whether we further
expand our enablement in-house service
provision
and
we also have seen a um although dealer
is sat next to me so i must say the
virus is out there it's not gone away
even though the press says it has it has
not gone away and it is still
circulating but i think last time when i
came
we had um a considerable number of homes
that were closed to admission because of
the
an outbreak in the home
and today we
have only a few homes that are closed um
it has gone up slightly this week it was
four last weeks ten this week out of 4
and 46 open so we're in a much better
place we are really maintaining that
infection control support to those
providers and in our home care provision
because it's really important that we
don't let this go and now that we've
regained the position
we are tracking five homes where they
have got
outbreaks again and arkan are struggling
in some ways but it is considerably
lower numbers than last time
and again residents are not particularly
unwell we have one home dealing with an
outbreak for residents at the moment
with five residents in total so the
numbers are really um considerably lower
than last time when i came
i also talked you through the work with
our home care providers where they were
struggling with the availability of
staffing due to uh staff absences for
omicron and and we were consider really
working to to reduce the impact of them
handing back care
and in the um last month we've had three
providers that have handed back care
provision but that's all been
reallocated
and we've had a lot of support from
those providers with managers out on the
floor actually delivering care but a lot
of support from families as well one or
two members have raised cases with me
and i've tracked and followed those
cases through for you and got you some
feedback on individual support
and so today in relation to our hospital
discharge work when i came last month we
were in
january certainly in a very difficult
place with around 60 people waiting for
discharges today we are down to 23
people waiting 10 of which were referred
yesterday and 6 today so we are really
um able to provide much quicker access
to support
however i have um
taken through executive uh the decision
framework and asked for it to be
extended it's going back into that
system
this this next few weeks i've asked for
it to be in place until the end of march
just so that we can really ensure that
sustainability as we move through and
through to easter particularly which
will follow quickly behind and the end
of this financial year and the only
demand area that i am concerned about
and continue to be monitoring and
tracking is the incoming activity coming
into social work for assessment so we
are seeing a really significant increase
in demand and naomi's here today but
working closely with our college and
colleagues in the ccg and acute sector
around the increased referral activity
we're seeing where people are waiting
for
an ongoing health care and support and i
know john's going to pick up the next
item around some of that acute um sector
provision
and so that's the area i'm watching and
i am just looking at whether we need to
bring in further additional capacity to
support social work teams
thank you chad i'll just take any
questions
thank you
do you have any
yes
um i just wondered with the increase in
its sort of referrals and presumably
sort of for assessment of need do you
have um a
like a home assessment service like a
home safe or
home to assess or anything
and so we have a we have uh locality
assessment teams in all of our borders
and we've got low assessment teams
linked to each of our hospitals uh with
all of the changes that we've had over
the last two years a lot of our
assessment now around the discharge to
assess and the tracking and supporting
of that first few weeks home has been
considerably enhanced the only risk i
see is that some of that is supported by
winter funding activity and short-term
funding and that is an issue that we are
flagging up through adas that as that
funding changes there is potentially
risk to it to increase activity not
being addressed as quickly as we've been
able to in the last six weeks really
hi um
uh you mentioned um those uh targets
around weeks and shortening them and did
you say those were a national target
so in your opinion do you think they're
achievable
well
thanks um i have a second question if
that's okay um
so
you mentioned kind of possible
investment in additional awards or
theaters
where what's the funding situation for
things like that and what kind of
restrictions are you working under
thanks and just one final question
thanks um so in terms of communication
with patients who are waiting
i imagine there's lots of repeat
contacts as people are trying to find
out where they are and then so you
become less productive because you're
too busy dealing with those what what
kind of plans are in place to
communicate with patients who are
waiting kind of in a more effective
manner
okay no i haven't heard of that that's
really interesting thank you
um finally just one last question on the
back of that um do you think are all um
hospitals and service providers taking
kind of the same approach to
communication or is there kind of
pockets of good practice that you know
maybe some could learn from
thank you
thanks chair um you may i think you have
partially answered this um
my concern is people that are waiting
for elective treatment
that are too passive
in their um approach because of covid
almost over understanding and
sympathizing with all the
how are we managing those
because to a certain extent i'm worried
that
to a certain degree that they're almost
parked and then their conditions may
deteriorate faster than
they were expecting
um so you you mentioned
trying to avoid exacerbating
inequalities um so what kind of
strategies are you looking at to ensure
that's the case
i think that's the word
um
thank you and um i just add a further
um
question uh obviously
um
you know i work in
a hospital setting and um
unfortunately communication is not
always what it should be and no doubt
sometimes um patients are being offered
uh you know appointments at short notice
i just wondered if you'd made any
but you know they may not hear about it
until too late and i just wanted to
check that there weren't any changes to
the system for dnas so
what would be terrible is obviously
someone's been waiting maybe over a year
for an appointment they're given an
appointment at short notice they're on
holiday they get back from the holiday
to find that they've been taken off the
waiting list so i just wanted some i
guess reassurance about about that
aspect what happens if they miss an
appointment or even they're in hospital
because they've waited so long um
and you know just that they're not
removed from the waiting list and have
to go back to the beginning
thank you that'd be really helpful
um
just going on uh
as a sort of supplement to that um the
other thing is covis is still around and
one of the things that has affected is
the post
um and it's still affecting the post i
don't get post every day
um and i know that appointments um
somebody
in in
appointments have been missed
because we just haven't received posts
um and that's true for a certain area
of of trafford and continues to be so so
how how
how is that taken i mean one of the
things is that if i get the doctor my gp
or my dentist
always texts me
um
and
i'd like what's your capacity your bed
capacity at the moment because i know it
was very high during covey
how far has it come down
the number of occupied beds
um yeah i would like to know what the
bed capacity is because also it's not
just about having some beds available
it's also having the staff
available as well and
um if we're in a state in the rest of
the country
is probably over subscribed with
patients in beds
so how how are they going to move around
them
maybe you've got a risk assessment of
all that
could could would it be possible to have
that as well
okay and then and the people who've been
waiting
um 104 weeks um
there are going to be some people who
will go privately how does how does that
fit into the system have you had more
referrals going directly through a
private
um
capacity but of course once it they may
be seen but then they still have to be
put into the general mix as well
some of them are so desperate to get
seen i think that they will do that
so um
so what contracts
so what contracts have you got to go
into the private sector
and if you can't tell me now i'd like it
later
and just a
a general point for me really um
i think it's fair to say that
people generally don't understand the
greatest manchester nhs structures um
and
the scope there for
um sort of messages
from
to be misunderstood because they're
they're listening to the wrong
part of the nhs
but i think what people do understand is
waiting
and
my um perception is at the as it is at
the moment um
people are being patient
uh about it because they understand the
background of what we've been through in
in the last
two years so so there is a
a store of goodwill there
um
but that won't persist forever and um
there will need to be a
demonstrable
um
reduction in in the waiting lists uh
because
people will be watching and of course
the media will be watching because uh
they uh they'll love those stories don't
they where they can go and have a good
kicking session
somebody like the nhs
so um
it really does
need that good will not to be taken for
granted and but to be
delivered for
i think i think um this way i'm
perceiving it from
talking to people about their uh
you know their their own circumstances
and how they see
things at the moment
so
okay any other
point sorry yes that's okay
be operated um
and obviously we want to get as much
and
so have you an experience of that at all
i mean
as um
a secondary care provider myself and and
having done pre-op assessments i would
say
there are two reasons that you've
kind of alluded to but the first one
generally is that if it is significant
surgery um the first pre-op assessment
may well be um
a sort of
um
more of a scoping exercise and some
patients may then need a further pre-op
assessment with an anesthetist rather
than a nurse
um so that would be the first
reason that someone might have two
separate pre-op assessments um and they
may well be done
um
in in any of the
just wherever is available to to to
carry out those checks but the other
would be that the pre-op assessment is
um specific to the type of surgery
that's being carried out so
if someone's having say urological
surgery
um
so for let's say a prostate um
[Music]
uh operation
um and then
they are also having uh they're also on
a waiting list for cardiac surgery the
kinds of the assessment for those two
different um surgeries would be really
very different
um and the anaesthetic would be very
different as well so they would have to
um
and you couldn't kind of have one
without the other really and so you
could say oh well um
let's let's just have it
say that they can do but obviously for
um efficiency
um most pre-op assessments are carried
out by
by nursing staff rather than getting
anaesthetists to do them all because it
would just be a poor use of time so
anesthetists would only see those that
were those cases that are very high risk
um
and then um basically you see a lot of
it is is kind of done on a pro forma
basis um
so you'd have a very different pro forma
for cardiac surgery to urological
surgery to to all the different ones and
you couldn't then say oh well this
person's also having surgery for that
because they'd be trained only to do the
pre-op free for urological surgery so
those are two different reasons there
are i mean there are further reasons
obviously i work at salford royal
unfortunately if a patient is having
neurosurgery for example which they
could only have
at um salford royal um it would have to
be a completely separate pre-op
assessment um
because we're not part of manchester
foundation trust so so again if they're
having something that's outside mft
um
then uh
and again christie's would probably that
they would do their own assessments
because they're a totally separate trust
so there are quite a few reasons there
unfortunately um but yeah the the main
sort of screening pre-op assessment is
done to be streamlined so it's very
specific to the surgery
one item i wanted to
cover with the
committee
i did ask at the last meeting if the
committee would be minded to
to write to the previous committee
chairman um
dr karen barkley
uh to thank her for her service and um
that was
generally thought to be a good idea
i just wanted to share the draft of the
letter with you
uh so it's uh
dear dr barclay i'm writing to you on
behalf of
uh trafford council health scrutiny
committee to thank you for your
leadership and commitment to the
committee and the trafford community
during the past two and a half years
during your time as chair you helped to
increase the levels of participation
with members of the public and bring
scrutiny
to the community most notably by having
the committee meet in altering them as
part of an inquiry into the ultrium hub
during the pandemic you were tireless in
your support of the trafford pandemic
scrutiny committee
and drove the re-establishment of the
health scrutiny committee
during your time as chair you ensured
the committee kept a strategic focus
upon the key health issues facing the
area
with a strong understanding of the
importance of the wider determinants of
health
you have helped to build strong
relationships with traffic councils
public health and social care teams
as well as health partners such as
trafford ccg and healthwatch trafford
which will continue to provide value to
the committee in coming years
when i spoke to officers and fellow
councillors upon my appointment it was
made clear to me that i have some big
shoes to fill
and i hope you'll be able to live
i hope i will be able to live up to the
high expectations you have set for the
position
you're sincerely so
that was the letter we won't try and
edit it by committee i think it will
be
so thank you for uh agreeing to that
um
and that i think concludes the
meeting for
today so thank you everybody for your
attendance and your contributions
some very um important points we covered
there and um
it'd be interesting to uh to follow up
on those in due course so thank you
everybody thank you